hi i'm annie taylor-joy and this is how
i became beth harmon
i fell in love with beth from the first
page when i first heard that scott frank
wanted to meet me there was no script
but i got sent the book
and i'm a very avid reader but even for
me i didn't
like read this book i devoured this book
so i was just so excited
and i saw a lot of parallels between
myself and this person
to use like a 2020 phrase i felt seen
you know like i really felt like this
was reflecting something back at me that
existed within me and i don't often
feel that way about characters because
characters for me
are other people that i feel empathy
toward but not necessarily like
it's me um and i i think i think the
main thing
between the two of us is beth is an an
inherently lonely person
and i definitely had that growing up and
we both
were searching for a world in which we
felt like we were
appreciated for the things that
potentially you know
other people that weren't part of that
world would say were our flaws
and i found it in making art and she
found it in chess
i'm fine being alone i feel safe in an
entire world of just
64 squares how beth reacts to herself
alone tells you pretty much everything
you need to know about her she is
both terrified of being alone and also
feels like it's the only place
where she's safe and that the fighting
of those two
impulses is what causes her such pain as
she's desperate to connect
and yet has been taught through her
childhood that everybody
will abandon her and nobody's going to
be there for her which is a pretty rough
lesson to learn at any age especially as
young as beth learns it and i do think
that's why she gets so
involved with chess she gets she gets
such a sense of security from
being able to predict what's going to
happen i think she actually
oh no i know she actually says if i get
hurt i only have myself to blame
beth has been so hurt by the world and
she doesn't necessarily understand what
she's done
to deserve that but yes any moment that
beth is
alone i think tells you a great deal
about her and it's also telling that
that's
a big part of when she does partake in
substances learning about addiction
one of the things i found most
interesting was that whatever it is that
the addict
is getting from the substance clearly
worked for a period of time
the awful thing about addiction is that
it is guaranteed to stop working and it
will completely derail your life and it
was very important for both scott and i
that you understood as the audience oh
this is beth drinking because she's
lonely this is beth taking the pills
because she feels too much
this is her drinking as a form of
punishment this is her drinking as a
form of celebration and like
understanding exactly what it is that
she's getting from it
um each time there is one player that
scares me
oh the russian
the chess sequences and the substance
addiction sequences were very
important to us and it was something
that scott and i spoke a lot about
at the very very beginning on our first
meeting because you know the show is
long it is seven hours and there's a lot
of chess and there's a lot of substance
abuse and so we had to make sure that
each time
it was fresh and exciting and it didn't
just feel like we were recycling
something consistently
and the beauty of chess is that it is
played usually between two people so
whoever is
opposite beth in whichever situation
does elicit a different reaction from
her
two of my favorite chess sequences are
the first time that beth plays towns
because it's the first time that she
doesn't necessarily want to beat someone
like it hurts her to win in the brutal
way that she does because
you know she likes a boy for the first
time
and the other one that i adore is the
first time beth meets a prodigy who is
younger than her
that gets her that really gets to her
that like
undermines her entire belief of self and
she just
i i asked scott i was like do i have
permission to like
fully attempt to psych out this kid like
i want to be
up i want to be moving i want to be
circling around in like a shark and she
was like
go for it and i didn't tell um i didn't
tell the boy that i was
playing with i was gonna do that and uh
it felt pretty good
tell the readers of life how it feels
and to be a girl
among all those men i don't mind it
one of the things that i find most
fascinating about beth
and something i think will resonate with
people is the fact that because she is
so intelligent because she sort of
exists in this kind of
like just outside of society even though
this is set in the 60s
she is genuinely baffled that people
care about her gender
like genuinely does not understand why
people are talking about her being a
girl
rather than the thrashing that she just
you know delivered to
whoever it was that she was playing and
having that
incredulousness having that lack of
understanding of like wait why does this
matter
was a wonderful thing to be able to
portray especially in the 60s but i
think something that will resonate with
a lot of people now today
because it's almost like she wasn't
gifted
the handbook that says you're a girl
this is what you're allowed to want
this is what you're allowed to dream
about this is what you're allowed to say
this is what you're allowed to
embody and because of that it very
quickly becomes that she's not
out there to be the best female chess
player she's out there to be the best
chess player period
and i hope that as a society we get to
move towards
a world where regardless of your gender
how you identify you're allowed to want
whatever you want and you're allowed to
follow whatever dream that you want to
follow
chess isn't always competitive
jess can also be
beautiful the fashion of queen's gambit
was so much fun
um i feel very very lucky that
scott felt like he had cast the right
person and so
i had a big heart to play within like
how we were going to
dress her up like the way that she was
going to look um the first thing i said
to scott was she needs to have red hair
like that was just something imperative
to me um because i wanted her to stick
out like a sore thumb wherever she went
and the journey that we go through with
beth in the clothes i think is
fascinating on two levels the first
being that
the age that she is when i get to start
playing her
is the age where typically people are
trying on different personas like
trying to see where they fit and i had
this idea that she sort of
would watch movies or like have a muse
and try and emulate that so you know she
goes to school and she sees the girls
there for the first time so she starts
to try and dress like them
and realizes ah now that doesn't work
for me then she sees her first audrey
hepburn movie and all of a sudden it's
you know the high neck black t-shirts
and um
cigarette pants and and it was just such
a great way of charging where she was
going and one of the conversations that
we had very early on was
people worrying that she was too
glamorous and i just thought that that
was the whole point
that it wasn't mutually exclusive that
you can be a brainiac
and like nice clothes at the same time
like it's not such a crazy expression
anymore
um and i love that she is
unapologetically feminine in that
because i think it would have been very
easy to go
oh she's a chess like genius so that
means that she obviously doesn't care
about clothes and i'm like
nah that's not the way that the story's
gonna go you just let them blow by
and you go on ahead and do just what how
you feel like
i think potentially some of the
experiences that i've had
um as myself really helped prepare me to
play beth i think
i was so lucky and i i genuinely
mean this i was so lucky that the first
people that i worked with
never made me feel like because i was
young or a girl i did not have a seat at
the table
and so when i showed up on the witch i
was a collaborator with robert you know
it was never like you hush up you sit
there you do what i tell you to do it
was a collaboration and i think
much in the same way that beth
experiences it in the chess world i was
sort of really shocked the first time
that i ever experienced like true sexism
on set i was like oh wow i've been
spared that
for ages um
so i think i had i had some of my own
uh experiences to draw to draw from
uh but by the time beth was done i i was
i was ready it was it was good
you